♪ ♪
>> Raymond: WELCOME BACK TO
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
WITHIN THE DOCUMENTS RELEASED BY
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY THERE WAS AN
INTERESTING OBAMA REVELATION.
HE KNEW ALL THE DETAILS OF THE
WIRETAP MICHAEL FLYNN PHONE
CALLS WITH RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR.
NOW, A DETAIL THAT WAS EVEN
SURPRISING TO TOP DOJ OFFICIALS
SALLY YATES, BUT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN?
NOT REALLY, GIVEN OBAMA’S
ATTENTION TO ALL THE POLITICALLY
TINGED INVESTIGATIONS AT THE
TIME, FROM THE HILLARY CLINTON
EMAIL PROBE TO THE ELECTION
MEDDLING INQUIRY, BUT OBAMA’S
INVOLVEMENT IN THE FLYNN CASE IS
TROUBLING FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH IS THE
FACT THAT OBAMA AND FLYNN HAD AN
UGLY BREAKUP IN 2014.
MOST PEOPLE FORGET THIS.
DURING HIS TENURE AT THE DEFENSE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY, FLYNN SPOKE
OUT AGAINST OBAMA’S WORLDVIEW.
HE WAS FIRED AS A RESULT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF ALL THIS?
HERE WITH A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE,
THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF
INTELLIGENCE FOR THE FBI.
WITH ALL OF YOUR EXPERIENCE, WHY
DID THE FBI CONTINUE TO PURSUE
FLYNN WHEN THEY HAD A TRANSCRIPT
AND KNEW HE HAD DONE NOTHING
WRONG?
WHY DO YOU THINK OBAMA GOT IN
THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF THIS?
>> THAT IS THE MILLION-DOLLAR
QUESTION.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT IT’S BEEN
PRETTY FIRMLY ESTABLISHED THAT
THE FBI HAD NO BUSINESS BEING IN
THE ROOM FOR FLYNN.
THAT’S THE FIRST PART.
THERE’S THREE PRONGS TO THIS,
RAIMENT, AND THAT IS THAT THE
FBI HAD TO -- WE HAD TO
ESTABLISH FIRMLY THAT MICHAEL
FLYNN -- THERE WAS INJUSTICE
DONE TO HIM.
I THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SETTLED THAT WITH THE MOTION
THAT WAS DISMISSED.
SECONDLY, THERE HAS TO BE SOME
EXAMINATION OF WHAT THE
MOTIVATION WAS BEHIND THAT AND
THIRDLY, SOMEONE HAS TO BE HELD
TO ACCOUNT.
THE SECOND PART IS WHAT YOU ARE
ADDRESSING HERE.
WE KNOW THAT FROM THE THREE OH
TWO THAT PETER STRZOK RODE THAT
THE INTERVIEW WAS FOCUSED ON
POLICY DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
OUTGOING OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND THE INCOMING TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
I HAVE AUTHORED AND READ
THOUSANDS OF 302S.
I’VE NEVER READ ONE LIKE THIS
FOR THE INTERVIEW WAS CENTERED
ON POLICY ISSUES AND DIDN’T EVEN
ADDRESS ANY POSSIBLE CRIMINAL OR
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE, OR
PREDICATION.
THE LOGAN ACT IS A DEFLECTION,
IT WAS NEVER TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
>> Raymond: THAT’S AN OLD
RELIC, HE NEVER SHOULD’VE BEEN
INVOKED.
ANDREW MCCABE FLAT OUT DENIED
ANY WRONGDOING ON CNN TODAY.
>> GENERAL FLYNN WAS NOT
TARGETED.
HE WAS PROPERLY INVESTIGATED IN
A WELL PREDICATED CASE, CASE
THAT’S BEEN PROVEN, NOT JUST BY
THOSE OF US WHO WERE INVOLVED,
BUT LATER BY THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
HAD REASON TO BELIEVE HE
PRESENTED A THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY.
I STILL THINK THAT THOSE THINGS
ARE WORTHY OF INVESTIGATION.
>> Raymond: KEVIN, WAS WHAT
HAPPENED TO GENERAL FLYNN AT
YOUR IDEA OF A PROPERLY
INVESTIGATED CASE, FIRST OF ALL?
WHAT’S WRONG WITH THAT?
>> WHAT ANDY McCABE JUST SAID
THERE IS AN UNTRUTH AND IT’S
BEEN ESTABLISHED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FBI’S OWN
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
RELEASED, THESE DOCUMENTS ARE
VERY TELLING.
THEY DOCUMENT THAT THERE WAS
NEVER A SIGNIFICANT PREDICATION
TO OPEN UP A CASE AGAINST HIM IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
THEY FOUND NO DEROGATORY
INFORMATION, NO REASON TO KEEP
THE CASE OPEN AND THEY WERE NOT
TO CONTINUE WITH AN INTERVIEW OF
THE GENERAL.
PETER STRZOK AND ANDY McCABE
GRABBED THAT, CASE CLOSED, AND
DECIDED TO CONSTRUCT SOME TYPE
OF ARTIFICE TO GO IN AND TALK TO
THE GENERAL, TOOK ADVANTAGE OF A
DISORGANIZED TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY HAD NO BUSINESS BEING IN
THAT OFFICE.
>> Raymond: KEVIN, ALL DAY
LONG I’VE BEEN HEARING THAT THIS
IS NORMAL OPERATING PROCEDURE
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO BE INVOLVED
IN THESE NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUES.
NO PROBLEM HERE.
WHY WAS SALLY YATES SURPRISED,
THEN, THAT HE HAD KNOWLEDGE OF
THE SURVEILLANCE?
VERY QUICKLY.
>> Raymond: I THINK THE
FACT THAT THE CONVERSATION TOOK
PLACE BETWEEN GENERAL FLYNN AND
WAS OF INTEREST TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, BECAUSE OF
POSSIBLE CHANGE IN POLICIES AND
B, BECAUSE OF THEIR POSSIBLE
DISTASTE FOR GENERAL FLYNN
GENERAL FLYNN.
I THINK THEY SAW THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISRUPT THE
GENERAL AND I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
TO FIND OUT, AND THIS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT, THAT THE
FBI CONDUCTED THIS INTERVIEW AT
THE BEHEST OF THE WHITE HOUSE,
OR WAS IT MOTIVATED BY THEIR OWN
NOW WELL-ESTABLISHED PERSONAL
BIASES AND PREJUDICES AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT THAT HAS
TO BE DETERMINED.
IF IT’S THE FORMER -- IF IT’S
EITHER, IT’S ABOMINABLE BUT IT’S
THE FORMER, THEN IT HAS TO BE
FLESHED OUT.
>> Raymond: BREAKING MOMENTS
AGO YAHOO NEWS IS REPORTING THAT
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA IN A
PRIVATE CLUB WITH FORMER MEMBERS
OF HIS ADMINISTRATION SAID THIS:
THE FACT THAT THERE IS NO
PRESIDENT FOR ANYBODY, THAT
ANYBODY COULD FIND, FOR SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
PERJURY, JUST GETTING OUT
SCOT-FREE, THAT’S THE KIND OF
STUFF WHERE YOU BEGIN TO GET
WORRIED THAT OUR BASIC
UNDERSTANDING OF THE RULE OF LAW
IS AT RISK.
KEVIN, YOUR RESPONSE?
>> MY RESPONSE TO THAT IS THE
RULE OF LAW WAS CONDUCTING AN
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS NOT
LEGALLY PREDICATED.
SO IF I GO IN AND I TALKED TO
YOU ABOUT SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
A FEDERAL CRIME, AS AN FBI
AGENT, AND I ACCUSE YOU OF DOING
IT AND I HAVE PROOF YOU DID IT
BUT IT’S NOT A FEDERAL CRIME,
AND YOU LIED TO ME, THERE’S NO
MATERIALITY THERE BECAUSE
THERE’S NO REASON FOR ME TO BE
INVESTIGATING IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
>> Raymond: BECAUSE I’M LYING
TO YOU ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE
NONCRIMINAL AND NOT RELEVANT.
>> EXACTLY, AND THAT IS WHAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR POINTS OUT
IN HIS MOTION.
MARY AND HEATHER --
>> Raymond: WE ARE GOING TO
LEAVE IT THERE BUT WE WILL